alors je vous le disais comme chaque
mercredi maintenant nous partons à la
découverte d'une école ou d'une
formation dans les Yvelines et c'est
avec vous Régina ralege bonsoir bonsoir
alors ce soir vous allez nous parler de
propriété intellectuelle et de droit du
numérique tout à fait Mathilde et c'est
l'université Versailles Saint-Quentin en
Yvelines qui délivre la formation pidan
c'est à dire propriété intellectuelle et
droits des affaires numériques on a avec
nous Benjamin Collot bonsoir vous êtes
étudiant en Master 2 dans cette
formation est-ce que vous pouvez nous
dire plus précisément ce que signifie
propriété intellectuelle et droit des
affaires numériques la propriété
intellectuelle c'est deux pans du droit
qui comprend notamment le droit d'auteur
la contrefaçon de marque et les brevets
et aussi tout plein d'autres domaines du
droit d'avoir le droit des contrats par
exemple on ne citer que ça au sein de
l'espace du numérique en fait tout
simplement est-ce que vous avez un
exemple à peu près vous faites un achat
sur Amazon il y a pas mal d'Inter qui se
passe à ce moment-là et c'est sur ça que
nous en tant que juriste ou avocat on
s'intéresse en tout cas on s'intéresse
aux enjeux autour de ça parce qu'il y a
évidemment une source économique
importante dans au sein du numérique et
pour ne pas aussi citer les données un
caractère personnel rgpd tout ça ça vous
dit ça vous évoque quelque chose et
justement cette formation elle est
délivrée par l'UVSQ et en quelques
chiffres le master de bidon c'est 25
étudiants chaque année 300 heures de
cours un taux d'employabilité à presque
100% un salaire médian à 2400 euros à la
sortie de l'école et en termes de
débouchés plusieurs métiers s'offrent à
vous comme consultant juriste ou avocat
en droit du numérique alors Benjamin
Collot vous avez un petit peu développé
ce que vous apprenez aujourd'hui en
Master 2 mais vous êtes passé par quel
parcours en fait vous avez fait une
licence d'abord moi j'ai fait une double
licence droit et LLCER anglais mais on
peut accéder à la formation en ayant
simplement fait une licence de droit
d'accord donc pourquoi pourquoi ce choix
vous avez commencé par de l'anglais puis
vous avez fini
en sortant du lycée j'avais une certaine
appétence pour l'anglais donc j'avais
envie de garder ça et le droit
m'intéressait énormément et puis au fur
et à mesure étant passionné de musique
je me suis le droit de la musique m'a
beaucoup intéressé et donc je me suis
tourné vers la propriété intellectuelle
et comme à l'heure actuelle tout ce qui
est question de streaming par exemple ou
téléchargement illégal sont des
questions qui sont vraiment d'actualité
je passe mes journées à étudier ça et
voilà donc c'est pour ça que je me suis
tourné vers ces études et justement dans
ce master quelles sont les cours que
vous voyez j'ai un cours de droit de la
musique par exemple sinon j'ai de la
protection des données personnelles ou
par exemple là on va étudier tout ce qui
est cookies en fait ce qu'ils ont droit
qu'est-ce qu'ils n'ont pas le droit de
mettre directement le fait que vous
puissiez tout refuser c'est une des
avancées du rgpd aussi
c'est le règlement général sur la
protection des données voilà sortie en
2016 si je vous dis pas de bêtises mais
voilà et donc dedans il y a un tas de
comment dirige de loi qui s'intéresse à
toutes ces questions entre vous chez un
internaute et les fournisseurs que ce
soit par exemple les gafams
Google Facebook Amazon etc etc et du
coup vous avez dû faire ou vous avez
fait des stages durant votre master
j'avais une double essence qui demandait
un peu qui prenait pas mal de temps et
donc on était pas obligé de faire un
stage maintenant il y a 100% de
d'étudiants qui trouvent dans notre
formation en tout cas un stage dans la
spécialité de leur choix et mais c'est
vivement encouragé de faire des stages
avant le master si vous en avez la
possibilité et pendant le master pendant
le master c'est obligatoire à la fin du
Master 2 on commence cette année j'ai
effectivement un stage et donc vous
allez faire votre stage dans quoi moi
j'aimerais bien viser ouais tout ce qui
est maison de disque en fait tout ce qui
est musicale c'est vraiment ce qui
m'intéresse le plus et notamment comme
je vous ai évoqué tout à l'heure la
question du streaming moi c'est vraiment
quelque chose qui m'intéresse énormément
et donc voilà j'aimerais travailler au
sein de ces sociétés afin de poursuivre
un peu mêlés passions entre guillemets
justement vous dites que vous aimez le
secteur musical donc il y a énormément
d'enjeux quel métier ce qu'on peut faire
dans ce secteur
que ce soit pour la maison de 10 pour
être avocat pour un artiste ou juriste
au sein d'une entreprise dans l'édition
musicale c'est vraiment les grands
changements et sinon notre formation
permet aussi de de devenir ce qu'ils
appellent aujourd'hui des PO qui sont en
gros les personnes référentes dans les
entreprises pour les données et voilà
donc ça vu que maintenant c'est
obligatoire par le rgpd sauf quand même
pas mal de portes et surtout un nombre
de secteurs en fait vraiment très varié
est-ce que dans cette formation vous
trouvez qu'il y a un point fort quelque
chose qui vous a vraiment aidé qui vous
aidera en tout cas notre quotidien à la
sortie de l'école
remarquer qui courait énormément de
données et c'est quand même une
formation plus de la moitié des courses
on fait par des professionnels donc ça
c'est quand même un énorme avantage et
surtout pour moi le point fort vraiment
de ma formation ce sont le fait que les
étudiants sont vraiment poussés à mener
des projets personnels et je sais mon
camarade qui est parti au Japon avec une
université qui était pas conventionnée à
la base mais qui a monté un projet et
qui avec l'aide des directrices de
Master a pu partir au Japon six mois
il aimerait bien travailler si je dis
pas de bêtises dans le secteur
audiovisuel en fait et mais du coup au
Japon donc il est parti au
japonais et puis apprendre un peu plus
sur les lois nationales là-bas parce que
évidemment c'est même plus on est en
dehors de l'Europe donc c'est vraiment
un cadre totalement différent là on est
sur droit international que ma formation
traite aussi du coup parce que là les
enjeux autour de notre formation le
demande d'avoir un côté vraiment
international
et du coup si vous aviez des conseils à
donner aux étudiants au lycéens qui
veulent rentrer en fait peut-être qu'on
va commencer par la licence parce que
c'est vrai que passer du lycée à la fac
c'est pas facile est-ce que vous vous
aviez vous avez des conseils alors
passer du lycée à la fac moi je dirais
c'est se connaître en fait c'est
peut-être le truc le plus important moi
personnellement ça met du temps mais
donc ça peut rassurer certain ça arrive
souvent au cours des études supérieures
pour la plupart d'ailleurs mais non
sinon je dirais d'être curieux et de
d'essayer de d'avoir une réflexion
intellectuelle un peu construite afin de
de découvrir avec merveilles j'ai envie
de dire que Dora ce sera beaucoup plus
intéressant que de voir ça comme une une
matière un peu qui peut paraître un peu
rude sur certains égards faut vraiment
se donner cette envie cette curiosité et
cette
ouais c'est envie de construire une
réflexion de un peu logique qui découle
naturellement à la fin voilà et pour
accéder à votre master du coup si vous
avez des conseils pareils à donner à ces
informations énormément d'actualité
énormément d'actualités c'est vraiment
le je pense le
principal vraiment avoir c'est vraiment
de s'intéresser aux questions
d'actualité puis évidemment lire ce qui
s'est passé avant afin de comprendre
mieux comment ça se passe maintenant
voilà je pensais vraiment le principal
conseil restez branché
merci beaucoup d'être venu en plateau
pour nous parler de votre formation